hey this is pressure locker today MIT
ranks as one of the top universities in
the world
nearly 150 years ago this question
appeared on its admissions exam the
perpendicular dropped from the vertex of
the right angle upon the hypotenuse
divides it into two segments of 9 and 16
feet respectively find the lengths of
the perpendicular and the two legs of
the triangle give this problem a try and
when you're ready keep watching the
video for the solution we'll get started
by drawing a diagram we have a right
triangle we're going to draw a
perpendicular from the vertex of the
right angle to the hypotenuse this
divides the hypotenuse into two segments
of 9 and 16 feet we need to find the
lengths of the perpendicular and the two
legs of the triangle the perpendicular
to the hypotenuse of a right triangle
creates a special set of triangles the
green triangle here and the blue
triangle here are similar triangles this
means the ratio of their lengths and
angles are the same
in particular the length of the shorter
leg of the green triangle to its longer
leg will be the same ratio as the length
of the shorter leg of the blue triangle
to its longer leg so we can set the
ratio of the shorter leg to the longer
leg of each triangle equal to each other
in the green triangle we have 9 divided
by P and in the blue triangle we have P
divided by 16 we can cross multiply
these fractions to get P squared is
equal to 9 times 16 which equals 144
this means P is equal to the positive
square root of 144 which is 12 so we've
solved for one part of the problem that
the perpendicular has the length of 12
we now need to solve
for the two legs of the triangle notice
that each leg of a triangle is equal to
the hypotenuse of one of these smaller
triangles we could use the Pythagorean
theorem to figure out the legs in the
green triangle the length of the
hypotenuse would be the square root of
the sum of the squares of the legs of
the green triangle and the same thing is
true in the blue triangle but we don't
need to go through these calculations if
we notice one more thing in each of
these triangles the ratio of the shorter
leg to the longer leg is three to four
so each of these smaller triangles is a
scaled up version of the three four five
right triangle so we can solve for the
hypotenuse by scaling appropriately the
green triangle has lengths which are
three times that of a 3 4 5 right
triangle which means its hypotenuse has
to be 3 times 5 which is 15
similarly the blue triangle is scaled up
4 times a 3 4 5 right triangle so its
hypotenuse will be 4 times 5 which is
equal to 20 and that's the solution did
you figure it out thanks for watching
this video please subscribe to my
channel I make videos on math and game
theory you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at Pashto
Walker and if you liked this video
please check out my books there are
links in the video description